gina carano and you guys remember gina
carano speaking of canceled culture and
people who get uh booted off platforms
for no good reason gina carano of course
the actress who was in the mandalorian
she is a conservative she happened to
tweet something uh conservative leaning
she was kicked off the mandalorian
disney plus got rid of her she's now
with the daily wire well she went back
on rogan a couple days ago and they're
still rogan's into this thing now and
they're talking about uh klaus schwab
the world economic forum and how they've
basically installed political leaders
even here right in america end up there
in canada the influencers the people
that step in and try to manipulate
things to get us to do one thing or the
other thing based on the amount of money
that they're getting from these special
interest groups
and so these people are they heads of
corporations or are they there's a lot
of that too yeah there's a lot of that
too there's a lot of the pharmaceutical
drug companies oil companies energy
companies
what they're doing they're what they're
trying to do is maximize their profits
right
that's what all these companies that are
if there's no reason for them to be
investing in politicians if it's not
profitable in the world economic forum
then that's bizarre
that's the most bizarre one the [ __ ]
dude who dresses like darth vader
[Laughter]
from the world economic forum he can be
in one of my movies he can bring his own
wardrobe that [ __ ] is wild he's
like a bad guy in a movie
well and then you can have justin
trudeau and gavin newsom right there
with him and it's like you gotta full-on
opportunity was a great reset
okay so
the reason i'm showing you this is
everyone's starting to talk about it i
know not mainstream media right so you
have to forget the layer that protects
the npcs the non-playable characters the
blue and non-people the blue-pilled
people who will never come around to
reality but everyone on the ground that
has one of these is starting to realize
there is something really weird going on
there when rogan is like yeah this guy
who see sounds like darth vader you know
he dresses like darth vader oh great
lisa is coming and it's like this is
this is like a hollywood script this guy
and then what gina is saying there and
you know he could have uh trudeau on one
side a new sim on the other i mean
trudeau is an acolyte of the world
economic forum all of the policies that
he's bringing to canada right now where
they are cracking down on misinformation
where they are making
all people who report on the news
register with the government where they
are now tracking
what you're doing online in in crazy
ways and i'm sure ways that we have no
idea of
these are ideas of the world economic
forum when you've got
uh the netherlands when you've got the
prime minister suddenly cracking down on
his own farmers who produce food for his
citizens is he doing that because he
thinks it's a great idea or does somehow
klaus schwab have his hands in that like
i know it all sounds nuts but we better
start thinking about this or we're not
going to realize what's going on here
before it's too late and perhaps it's
too late right now or you could also
connect this to a guy like gavin newsom
what has gavin newsom done in california
well you know my feelings on that he has
done everything possible to
intentionally destroy the state and if
you haven't been to california although
i don't recommend anyone go to
california
santa monica in particular because as my
buddy john kept saying when we were
there michael what did he say it smelled
like
urine cakes that's right not just urine
urine is a very specific smell which all
of santa monica smells like that but the
urine cake which is supposed to uh you
know hide the urine smell uh that's what
santa monica actually smells like more
because they're spraying urine cake
smell all over the urine
sidebar point is uh if you were to go to
california you could drive from say los
angeles socal up north and everywhere in
the farming country which is the bulk of
the middle of california all there are
are farmers with signs saying we cannot
get water uh vote out gavin newsom et
cetera et cetera gavin newsom
much like justin trudeau is instituting
policies that are destroying the place
he is supposed to protect right that's
what a governor is supposed to do you're
supposed to
create the conditions so that your state
or your country uh can flourish and what
justin trudeau has done up in canada we
know canada has tons of people leaving
right now people have absolutely had it
we know the truckers are uprising we
know that uh that all the stuff that
they are doing related to the internet
and everything else this is evil
authoritarian stuff that it was if it
was happening
via say a brown middle eastern leader
right
in an arab country we would be saying
it's the worst possible thing but when
our own guys do it to us we're very
confused